monfort mélanie poker avec la baisse des
températures arrive souvent la neige
vous avez sans doute gardé en mémoire
l'épisode neigeux de février dernier
alors sur les routes c'était la pagaille
près de 7 139 km de ralentissements en
ile de france
rappelez-vous certains ont dû abandonner
leur véhicule en bord de route
les yvelines ont connu une première
alerte au mois de novembre même si les
flocons n'ont pas tenu et les
collectivités sont déjà en alerte ont
fait le point avec vous mais là ni le
département est mobilisée depuis le 12
novembre il ya d'ailleurs eu un premier
salage préventif le 20 novembre dernier
pour les chutes dont vous parliez à
l'instant
ce plan est installée jusqu'à la mi mars
deux centres d'exploitation sont
opérationnels saint cyr l'école et
orgeval avec cinq agents ils sont
d'astreinte chaque semaine pour faire du
salage préventif des 450 km de routes
départementales de secteurs urbains il
faut savoir qu'en plus de nos agents on
a un responsable d'astreinte sur
l'ensemble de ce secteur qui lui est
plus chargé de surveiller la météo la
veille au soir d'organiser des sorties
en tant que de besoin en fonction de ses
prévisions météorologiques
les interventions se décide pas au pied
levé en général c'est l'après midi du
l'après midi on décide si on va sortir
la nuit et en fonction des prévisions
météorologiques ont également capable
d'anticiper si la situation va être
critique sur deux trois quatre jours et
une douzaine d'agriculteurs prêtent main
forte au top mais main-forte pardon aux
agents pour dégager certaines voies de
circulation mélanie l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines a aussi son
plan hivernal et ce plan là lui a débuté
le 1er décembre dernier et doit prendre
fin du côté du 31 mars
l'an passé les agents ont même travaillé
au delà de ces dates
alors pour les douze communes ce sont
douze engins qui sont prêts à intervenir
en fonction de la météo et un engin de
secours pour suppléer en cas de panne ou
d'incident ce sont dix personnes qui
sont en charge des 320 kilomètres au
sein de l'agglomération
l'objectif c'est de rendre les voies
carrossables ou empêcher qu'elles ne
deviennent difficiles de circulation
donc c'est du préventif d'abord avant
toute chose en fonction des bulletins
météo du salage de la saumure de la
saumure qui est
non polluante qui préserve la qui
préserve l'environnement et qui est plus
efficace efficace que le salage
traditionnels alors pour être tenu
informé saint quentin en yvelines vous
invite à vous inscrire sur le site peps
points ce qui point fr il suffit juste
d'entrer votre adresse mail pour
recevoir les alertes si on vous avait
parlé des routes qu'en est il des
trottoirs mais la nuit alors si un
arrêté du maire le prévoit c'est à vous
de déneiger le trottoir devant trouve
votre domicile il faut donc déblayer la
neige est assurée le sablage ou le
salage en cas de verglas et surtout ne
pas obstruer les bouches d'égout
le non respect de ces mesures vous
expose à 38 euros damende mais pour le
moment pas d'inquiétude la neige n'est
pas annoncée sur les yvelines merci
mélanie pour cette chronique